Rather than trying to just put a few
pennies into our paid ad spend, we
actually decided to go and target where
people are going to be drinking, where
people are going to be using our
products. So, we targeted retail first
and foremost before we really hammered
down the uh the paid ad side of things.
And that started with just getting our
first few like mom and pop liquor stores
in the city that we had already built
connections with prior. and it
eventually snowballs to where we got our
first purchase order with Foxtrot in
Chicago, which is one of our biggest
accounts um to date.
where we try to go from there now is
that now that we're actually bringing in
a little bit more money from the uh the
liquor stores that we sell at, the
convenience stores, and also now the
bars and events that we sell at, we've
been able to invest a little bit more
into our paid spend across Amazon,
across Meta, and we're looking to
continue to ramp that up as our uh
revenue continues to grow.
Daniel Addex, welcome to 20 minute
leaders. I'm so excited to have you here
all the way from Chicago. How are you?
>> I'm doing really good, Michael. Thank
you for having me.
>> No hangover, right?
>> Absolutely not. Not not in our book.
>> Not in our book. And then uh today we're
going to talk about uh the awesome
founding story of Leure. uh and uh I as
I mentioned I've been getting so
interested in in consumer goods and
consumer brands and how one goes about
creating and growing uh the consumer
goods both zero to one and and beyond.
And so I'm I'm excited to share your
story here uh with with myself and and
those tuning in to this. Uh so again
thank you for joining me.
>> Yeah, let's do it.
So, take me back to to the founding of
Leure and what makes one decide that
they're going to start a new brand and a
new consumer good?
>> Absolutely. So, it all goes back to uh
my my upbringing. I grew up in the state
of Wisconsin and what Wisconsin is known
for outside of our dairy is our drinking
culture. It's one of the strongest
drinking cultures in the entire world.
And as soon as I went to college, I went
to the University of Wisconsin. So, you
kind of immerse yourself as a part of
this uh work hard, play hard culture,
and
you'd enjoy yourselves on the weekends.
Um, but as soon as the diploma hit your
hand, the day after drinking just became
significantly worse for myself,
regardless of how mindful I was being of
my own consumption. And my co-founder
for this, he also went to a party school
down in Florida. So he had a very
similar experience where after having so
much fun during his four years and how
responsible he was being about going out
and having fun, it just didn't feel the
same health-wise the morning after. So
we got really curious how we could
essentially bulletproof our body to be
able to weather the storm. And that's
when we got introduced to our main
ingredient in our gummies. It's called
DHM dehydroyetin.
What that is, it's an extract from the
Japanese raisin tree that actually
increases the amount of enzymes that
your liver produces in order to
metabolize alcohol more efficiently. And
there have been a lot of other formats
of this DHM on the market. So there were
liquids, there were pills already, and
each of these mediums had their own
faults to them. But no one had been able
to put this DHM into a gummy format. And
after going through the manufacturing
trials, I understand why it took so long
for someone to come out with one on the
market. But
we we took the DHM in the pill form at
first. We realized, oh wow, we feel so
much better the next day. What else is
this in? And that's when we realized
there was this gap in the uh the gummy
space at least. So, we spent the next 18
months working with multiple different
manufacturers, dietary supplement
chemists across the country to be able
to infuse this DHM into a gummy format.
And then back in April of 24, we did our
hard launch. And uh it's been uh it's
been so much fun ever since the journey.
I wouldn't trade it for anything, even
the days that have been uh pretty
cumbersome.
>> Yeah, I'm sure. Can can you do you
remember the day you launched? What what
what happened then? Yeah, the day that
we launched that was April 1st and we
actually did like a very soft launch
that we thought was going to be our
original one back in October of 23,
October 2nd. We had done like a big
launch party in the city of Chicago. We
rented out a venue for it and we were
able to get a lot of great consumer
feedback, not only from our peers, but
also individuals that were coming
because they heard about this brand new
product that was going to help them feel
better after drinking. And from some of
the feedback that we received,
>> was that basically by the way a party
that you just bring you bring a lot of
people, you have them drink a lot, take
the product, and then the next So
basically, okay.
>> Yeah. What better way to kick off a
product like this than by having an open
bar and we got so much great feedback on
the efficacy of it at this event, but we
also were receiving mixed feedback on
the format, the flavor of it. Um,
essentially our manufacturer,
our first manufacturer for our original
bulk run, we had gotten samples prior
that looked great, tasted great, and
they worked really well. However, when
the bulk production went in, uh, the end
product kind of looked awful, kind of
tasted awful, but it still worked really
well. So, we're like, all right, we
don't want this to be a sunk cost. Let's
at least see how people are responding
to it on the market. And uh it was very
similar feedback that what we were
expecting. They were co they were
commenting on the flavor. They were
commenting on the appearance. And my
co-founder Logan and I, we both realized
that this is not the product that we
wanted to go and take to market. So, it
was a really tough decision, but we
ended up um halting production of that
product and halting our sales and went
back to the drawing board for another
few months before we found the right
partner in our current manufacturer that
was able to get us a product much closer
to what we had envisioned moving
forward.
>> Wow. And how so how does launching a
product like this actually look like in
today? So, you're in April of 2024 and
you're saying, "Okay, great. I now have
the manufacturing. I have the product."
how and and and you have maybe some you
know a hyper focused group in Chicago
that's already you know friends family
and and and the community around how do
you actually now grow this is it mainly
social mainly advertisements what are
the strategies
>> yeah so our product is a little bit
different than traditional CPG brands so
the normal playbook that we'll see for a
lot of uh consumer products is that as
soon as you launch you want to be
hammering uh as much money as you can
into your paid ad budget. We were in a
little bit of a a a different stance
because the money that we had already
wanted to save and use for paid ad
spend, we had to go into a completely
new manufacturing run. So that ate a lot
of our costs. But rather than trying to
just put a few pennies into our paid ad
spend, we actually decided to go and
target where people are going to be
drinking, where people are going to be
using our products. So, we targeted
retail first and foremost before we
really hammered down the uh the paid ad
side of things. And that started with
just getting our first few like mom and
pop liquor stores in the city that we
had already built connections with
prior. and it eventually snowballs to
where we got our first purchase order
with Foxtrot in Chicago, which is one of
our biggest accounts um to date.
where we try to go from there now is
that now that we're actually bringing in
a little bit more money from the uh the
liquor stores that we sell at, the
convenience stores, and also now the
bars and events that we sell at, we've
been able to invest a little bit more
into our paid spend across Amazon,
across Meta, and we're looking to
continue to ramp that up as our uh
revenue continues to grow.
>> And so, how big of a strategy do you
think or do you envision that? social
will have and direct to consumer will
have on on liquor rather than retail.
>> It's definitely going to have a role. We
have been kind of unlucky in trying to
figure out how we want to
utilize creators in order to promote our
product because with a product in the
alcohol aid space, it's very heavily
scrutinized by the FDA, the FCC, what
you're able to say and the claims that
you're able to make about the product.
So, we'll have someone that makes a 10
out of 10 video, but then they make some
type of claim that is impermissible and
unfortunately we either have to edit the
video like heavily or we can't even post
it. So, our biggest thing is making sure
that we can give the right guidelines to
our creators, our ambassadors, and make
sure they're saying the things that are
uh approved in order to be able to not
only recirculate their content, but also
be able to post it on our own page um
and continue to build out our branding.
The the biggest thing that we're focused
on right now is making it as easy as
possible for someone that wants to post
for us, someone that wants to be an
ambassador or someone that we even hire
to be able to make the appropriate
claims, sell the benefit of feeling
great the morning after drinking. Um, so
there's a lot of things that we can do
with socials and a lot of it is going to
come down to being able to get con
creators and also getting them to uh
say say the say go about the product in
the in the right way, saying the right
things,
>> right? And and so how how do you
actually go about that? you have. So it
sounds like you want to bring those with
the right reputation, the these either
know these influencers, these creators
to come and validate and expl and
express the their own experience. On the
other hand, you you need to be very
careful. They don't know the FDA
regulations. Maybe they're super excited
about the product and they just want to
share that with the world, but but very
quickly realize that they're saying
things that are not appropriate or that
you can't use yourself. By the way, if
they do that, do you have I mean,
they're posting it on their own social
media as well. Do they have to take it
down or or can they keep that up and you
can enjoy those benefits?
>> So, that's a great question. what we can
and can't do is that if they do post
something where they talk about us as a
I I won't even say some of the claims
right here, but if they say some claims
that that we couldn't approve of or the
FDA would look down heavily upon, we as
a company can't interact with the
content. So, we can we can leave it up,
but we can't like repost it on our
account almost as like a cosign to us
saying like, "Yes, this is true. This is
correct." like we we will do X Y and Z
as long as they have it up but we don't
have any affiliation it does help a lot
but then we also can't repost it we
can't help them out um so a lot of it is
uh especially for like Tik Tok shop
that's where things get a little bit
more confusing the FDA has not
necessarily vetted the Tik Tok shop
space as heavily as they have for Meta
as for Amazon Um, and that allows us to,
you know, have creators that some like
we still give them the guidelines on
what to say and we don't encourage any
type of like outside language to be used
about our product. But in the event that
someone does kind of circumn these rules
and post something that maybe we would
wouldn't post, they're still able to
have their link to our product in their
uh in their video and reap some of the
commission benefits from it. we just
can't co-sign it then ma
>> makes a ton of sense and how do you get
how do you get them to to want to
endorse the product? So what is the
strategy that you would employ to try
and get these creators to say I want to
I want to share my experience with the
with this product? I mean they they must
be getting a ton of requests or maybe or
maybe not. D you you you're the expert
here.
Yeah, people are always looking for the
next product that they can really figure
out how to sell just so that they can
get their commission rates up. Uh how we
position ourselves to a lot of these uh
individuals is that we are typically
going after the people that are one
either they don't drink too much on a on
a regular basis so that when they
actually do they feel it a lot more and
they need to be able to be at their best
the next day and we send them over a
sample. We let them try out the product
themselves so they can see, okay, I
actually feel so much better after a
couple of drinks last night and I took
these gummies and now I want to be able
to like speak the praise about this. I
want to be able to push this to as many
people as we can. So my peers, my
followers are going to have a great
morning the next day. The other people
that we go after are like the actual
party animals, like the work hard, play
hard people that like, all right, you
affiliate, you associate them with going
out, getting after it, but they also get
their stuff done the next day. So, it's
either the people that we're targeting
are those that will drink but rarely, or
the people that are drinking all the
time, but they're still hyperactive and
they're really trying to make sure that
they can do a lot of what they do um the
following day. where like we we also at
a as a young company, we're okay with
giving up a little bit of margin right
now to give higher commission rates to
those that are actively selling our
product because on Tik Tok shop with all
of these restrictions that we have on
what we can say, the ones uh that
actually do sell our product, we want to
give them a little bit more credit for
being able to push that. So, we're
totally okay with giving them a little
bit more, especially while we're young.
Is it challenging tying the benefits of
the product with
with the delay that from when it was
taken? For example, you know, you're
mentioning that you take the product at
11 p.m. on a on a Friday. You only see
the benefits at 9:00 a.m. on Saturday or
10 a.m. on Saturday, right? Is there a
>> is it a challenge to correlate these two
events?
>> Yeah, it definitely is because it's hard
to do like before and after for any type
of beauty product. You'll be able to see
like a before and after. Oh my like my
skin didn't look as good in this. I used
the product now look at the skin after
it. It's hard to really put that into uh
like a visual frame like the all right
you can send you can show a picture of
someone with like their head hanging in
a toilet and then the next day there's
not um but that's that's hard to do and
then that starts to get a little bit
more foggy as far as like FDA
compliance. So, where we struggle with a
little bit right now, honestly, is
finding a way to sell like the delayed
gratification. Um, typically our best
consumers are the ones that have tried
our product, say like, "Wow, this
absolutely works." And then they go out
again and perhaps they don't repurchase
in the moment, but then they feel how
they are in absence of our product and
say, "Oh my gosh, I feel awful today.
Like, I wish I had these gummies." and
that's when we get our repeat customers
from. So, it definitely is difficult
trying to figure out how we're supposed
to sell something that you don't see the
benefit of until you open your eyes the
next morning,
>> right? And let's talk for a second about
the about retail. Um, you mentioned that
you were able to get it into those local
stores through the relationships you've
built with them, but I I'm really
curious how that actually plays out. How
do you go ahead and build relationships
to the point where they're willing
themselves to put you up on their on the
shelf and and market you to their
customers?
>> Yeah, definitely. We've been positioning
ourselves as an impulse product in our
convenience stores. And it's a little
bit of a complicated uh space for
getting onto like the uh the countertop
trying to be position ourselves amongst
like a bunch of other products that
people are typically grabbing like right
out the gate. Like for example, our one
of our biggest liquor stores to start
with, they would sell like limes as
where you check out. They would sell
wands that would help remove the purity
of uh or remove the impurities from the
wine that consumers would be drinking.
And we uh sold ourselves to a lot of
these newer retailers as the uh the
perfect upsell to any alcohol purchase
because if anyone's going to be buying a
six-pack, they're definitely going to be
feeling it the next day. Um, a lot of
the times that we would take or a lot of
the times that we would have to build
confidence with these retailers,
especially as a young company, was
through consignment. So, you're they're
not necessarily going to buy from you
right away, but if you can prove that
the product sells, they'll pay it for
they'll pay you for it after. And it
wasn't obviously our choice. We'd love
to be paid upfront, but especially as we
were like in our first one to 30
locations in Chicago, you got to do what
you got to do. And we knew that the
product was going to sell and we knew
that people were going to be able to see
and feel the benefit of it. So, we kind
of took a bet on ourselves as far as
putting all of our uh inventory on
consignment in the early stages, but
then that begins to snowball. you get
into enough locations where you are able
to sell it at uh a wholesale rate to
them right out the gate right uh at the
start of the uh the relationship, people
then will continue to buy. They start to
reorder and you're able to use that
velocity and that momentum and take
those numbers to some of the larger
retailers that we've gotten into. Like
now, for example, we're in uh several
local 7-Elevens in Chicago, which is a
bit unique. Um, the Bar Stool Sports Bar
in uh downtown Chicago even took us on
as a a cocktail garnish for some of
their cocktails. And uh the Foxtrot one,
that was the biggest thing with uh
building a relationship with that buyer,
taking uh the momentum that we've had
with uh with our other mom and pop
retailers um and bringing that to them,
showing that this is a product that will
work in an impulse setting. A lot of the
times we also did sell the fact that we
are a Chicago based company and founders
of or owners of the the mom and pop
locations. They definitely were more
often than not looking to support a
brand that was rooted right in their
backyard.
>> Super interesting. What What are you
most excited about for this upcoming
year?
>> What I'm most excited for is the
festivals that we've been sponsoring. We
actually just got off a two-week stretch
where we did back-to-back festivals in
Chicago and one of them was the biggest
street festival uh in the entire city.
It's called Taste of Randolph. We had
over a 100,000 people there across the
weekend. And we were able to sell
thousands of dollars worth of product
there. And that momentum from uh how
well we did at this festival has not
only gotten us uh a few articles written
on uh publications, but also we've had
other festivals within the city and the
Midwest looking to form partnerships
with us because they kind of realize
like okay, no one else is doing recovery
uh at these festivals. and clearly lure.
What we're doing right now is we're kind
of trailblazing the recovery category to
show that people can still enjoy these
uh these times with their friends, their
peers at these settings and then feel
good enough to be able to not only run
it back the next day, but then let's say
come Monday, they're able to hop right
back into work and uh continue their
busy lives. So, that's where we see
ourselves as a fit. And the especially
with football season coming up for uh
universities, there's a lot of uh sports
coming and there's a lot of events that
we want to position ourselves at that no
other alcohol brands or alcohol aid
brands have really successfully been
able to penetrate up to this point. So
there's a lot to look forward to.
>> Daniel, I really want to thank you for
your time. I want to wish you best of
luck with LURE. Sounds like an awesome
founding story. Sounds like a lot of ups
and downs, big decisions made along the
way and then mainly an exciting future
ahead and and a good product. Sounds
like a it's really valuedriven and and
based on feedback and and solving a real
problem that I think everybody listening
here above 21 or 18 in other states,
other countries can relate to. So
Daniel, thank you so much for the time
and best of luck with Leure. Yeah,
Michael, I really appreciate it. And if
I'm ever in New York, let's definitely
get a drink
>> and and delure while drinking.
>> All right. They know.